do you know how large the audience's
that you'll speak to oh um well I don't
know it's not the largest of the rooms
but i believe from the sounds of it it's
a fairly large room this will be my
third panel in this genre did comikaze
expo last fall which was probably about
50 people and wondercon this spring
which was probably about seven or 800 so
i'm guessing comic i mean i guess a few
thousand i guess you've got a couple
hundred rsvp'd already on the facebook
page and yeah i mean i dont it's crazy
like I mean these patent you've been a
comic on these panels or like kind of
huge and like if you're in the audience
and you have to ask question you
actually have to get up and get in line
for the microphone um yeah I have no
idea so what do you do to prepare for
that or do you do nothing you just want
it to be spontaneous and your answers to
be real or do you think notes of what
they might ask you what your answers
might be I don't even make notes I'm
thinking about cutting out carbs and
sugar for the next three weeks that's
one way I'm preparing but in my head
I've had like the past couple days I'm
thinking of like what kind of topics we
might talk about and you know actually
this interview with you helps a lot
because a lot of these things will
probably come up on that panel um so
I'll sort of have some answers in my
head but no I am I never write downloads
I actually don't ever even write down
notes when I'm doing my living on a
dream show like I just yeah um yeah I am
NOT an I'm not a note girl at all I just
the only time I ever wrote down notes
was I had a panel seven of the actors
from Dexter and I had just been
introduced the show it was actually at
this actually a sag foundation event
that they asked me to moderate because
the regular person
around and they were like have you ever
seen dexter no it was the beginning of
season two and so I got like a
four-episode promo kit sent to me and I
watched every episode and I googled and
so then I like just Google each actor
that was on there and type down pages
and pages of notes and things that they
had been on and I mean there was no
other way to do it was me and like seven
people okay and um yeah I've just um
I've always been like a really nail
granite most of the interviews I've done
are people that I'm already familiar
with their work and know stuff about
them you know like the Skid Row guys you
know I've you know I've been a fan skid
row for 20 years so it's like I know
what to ask you um but yeah as far as
it's your boss really I think he's not
in control anymore yeah but anyways
although there's slight talk of a slight
reunion but they're always happens but
but they've been doing good without him
um anyways sorry we're gonna go rock and
roll ghaznavi now yeah so i don't i
don't know i have to trust Bonnie Burton
is our moderator and I have to trust
that Sheila she'll keep us all in line
but you know there's a bunch of crazy
gals on the panel and I like roussanne
Holly Conrad from the comic con
documentary and I've never met Holly but
she seems lots of fun and then on
adrianne Curry is also on the panel and
from what I've heard about aging she's a
little wild I think I think she got in
trouble last year comic-con because she
had an outfit that had no backside to it
oh okay I don't know the exact details
but I think like she had to be escorted
for you know wardrobe change or
something so it should it should be a
lot of fun it's being toted it's like
the hottest panel at comic-con very cool
yeah well we know they did some wardrobe
things that you'll
just yeah I might go with my fangs I
don't know oh no this will soon
you